c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
quelle classe at-il redoubler la
première effectivement que la première
la lie quelle classe est il redouble et
par quelle place at-il triple attention
cela n'est trop facile je passe à la 6e'
règlement ou et il grandit
il a beau lilas dans le 93 serena est
très forte
c'est incroyable je suis le nom du lycée
à égalité qui attendaient asie allez
c'est elle c'est quoi hélène boucher
délit folie là à du lycée oui mais c'est
l'islam est la raison mais c'est sûr que
la raison attendant j'étais au lycée
hélène-boucher charlemagne turgot marie
curie avançait plus je vois mais sans
appeler à la raison hélène boucher sa
loge et est maintenant on va rentrer
dans un truc et hélène boucher qui est
pas du tout bush éditrice fois c'est
vrai que c'était pas une question il
faut mentionner attention vous quelle
est celle est plus dure qu'elle et sa
manie jeu j'ai pas fini avec la neige à
palerme et quoi elle songe à l'est pour
les audiences bah ouais le jour des
audiences il porte un caleçon viol et
que les offert saveur
je suis catalan n'a pas les réponses
sans déconner elles sont bon dieu
bénisse tuchan thimoté
[Musique]